WE DON’T NEED TO TUNE IN TO
WHAT WE SAW YESTERDAY EVER
AGAIN.
HERE THE HOST OF JUSTIFIABLE
JEANINE SHIR ROW.
JUDGE, ANY COURT THAT YOU
WALK IN TO IN AMERICA I HAVE
TO GO THROUGH A METAL
DETECTOR, ANY ONE THAT I
HAVE EVER BEEN.
IN I ALSO HAVE TO PRESENT AN
I.D. IN ANY COURT I HAVE
EVER BEEN TO.
ANY TIME I HAVE BEEN TO
CONGRESS.
EVERY RNC AND DNC CONVENTION
EVERY BALLGAME I GO TO AND
EVERY OFFICE BUILDING IN NEW
YORK.
CAN WE NOT DO SOMETHING
BETTER INSTEAD OF THE SAME
OLD ARGUMENTS?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, SEAN,
YOU’RE SO RIGHT AND WHAT YOU
SAID CERTAINLY RANG TRUE TO
ME WHEN WHENEVER SOMETHING
LIKE THIS HAPPENS WE GO TO
THE OLD ARGUMENT.
THE SECOND AMENDMENT PEOPLE
SAY THE RIGHT OF THE
INDIVIDUAL TO POSSESS OR
BEAR ARMS SHALL NOT BE
INFRINGED.
AND THEN ON THE LEFT THEY
SAY THAT GUNS KILL PEOPLE.
I THINK SHOOTERS KILL
PEOPLE.
BUT LET ME START BY SAYING,
SEAN, NUMBER ONE, THAT AS
THE D.A., I WOULD OFTEN HAVE
TO TELL A PARENT THAT THEIR
CHILD WAS THE VICTIM OF A
HOMICIDE.
SO MY HEART GOES OUT TO ALL
OF THOSE PARENTS AND ALL OF
THOSE PEOPLE WHO KNEW THE
VICTIMS HERE.
WE NEED TO BE VERY CLEAR.
THIS IS NOT A POLITICAL
ISSUE.
THIS IS NOT AN ISSUE ABOUT
THE LEFT AND THE RIGHT AND
THE NRA.
ACTUALLY, I’M SICK OF
HEARING THE NRA AND IN THE
INTEREST OF FULL DISCLOSURE.
LET ME SAY I HAVE MANY GUNS.
I HAVE LONG GUNS.
I HAVE HANDGUNS.
THIS IS REALLY ABOUT THE
INDIVIDUAL AND IN THIS CASE
AN INDIVIDUAL WHO NOT ONLY
THREATENED AND POSTED
HIMSELF ON YOUTUBE AS
SOMEONE WHO WANTED TO BE A
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOL SHOOTER,
BUT THAT INDIVIDUAL HAD BEEN
EXPELLED FROM SCHOOL.
HE HAD ALL KINDS OF PERSONAL
PROBLEMS.
AND, YET, HE WAS ABLE TO
PURCHASE A GUN.
WHY WAS HE ABLE TO PURCHASE
A GUN?
BECAUSE BACKGROUND CHECKS,
TO BE HONEST WITH YOU ARE A
JOKE IN THE SENSE THAT IF
YOU ARE ON CYCLE TROPIC
DRUGS, IF YOU HAVE BEEN IN A
MENTAL INSTITUTION, HIPPA
LAW PROTECTS US AND I USED
TO SIGN PISTOL PERMITS ALL
THE TIME AS A JUDGE.
IT PREVENTS US, THE HIPPA
LAWS FROM, FINDING OUT WHAT
YOUR MENTAL HISTORY IS ALL
THE BACK ADOS FROM ADAM
LANZA AND SCHOOL SHOOTERS
FROM AURORA, COLUMBINE THEY
CAN GET THEM WITH NO PROBLEM
ALTHOUGH SOME GOT THEM FROM
THEIR PARENTS.
THAT’S NOT THE POINT.
YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
WE NEED TO PROTECT KIDS U
THAT MEANS WE HAVE GOT TO
HAVE METAL DETECTORS.
WE HAVE GOT HAVE EXPERIENCED
COPS.
I DON’T CARE IF THEY ARE
RETIRED OR SKILLED COPS
WORKING IN THE SCHOOLS.
WE HAVE GOT TO HAVE PATROLS.
WE HAVE TO HAVE TEACHERS WHO
CAN CARRY A WEAPON AND REACT
TO THIS KIND OF NONSENSE.
BECAUSE OUR KIDS DESERVE OUR
PROTECTION, SEAN.
>> Sean: LOOK, I’M NOT
SAYING -- I KNOW SCHOOLS
THAT RIGHT NOW, IF YOU ARE A
PARENT THERE IS ONLY ONE
DOOR YOU ARE GETTING.
IN THEY DO HAVE SECURITY AT
THESE SCHOOLS.
THERE IS ONLY ONE DOOR.
AND EVEN IF THEY KNOW YOU, I
HAVE GONE INTO SCHOOLS WHERE
HI, MR. HANNITY, I NEED YOUR
I.D.
FIRST THING THEY WOULD SAY.
NO EXCEPTION.
>> YOU CAN DO THAT AT A
BUILDING IN NEW YORK CITY.
THEY WILL SAY HI JUDGE
JEANINE, DO YOU HAVE YOUR
I.D.?
WAIT A MINUTE, WE’RE IN NEW
YORK CITY, YOU KNOW OHIO AM.
BUT I AGREE WITH YOU, SEAN.
WHAT WE HAD HERE THOUGH WAS
A WARNING THAT WE HAVEN’T
HAD IN OTHER CASES.
AND WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO
THE FBI, IF THEY DESERVE IT,
BASED ON EVERYTHING WE ARE
HEARING, ABOUT I DON’T WANT
TO HEAR ANOTHER FBI AGENT GO
UP TO A MICROPHONE AND SAID
WE HAD NO FURTHER
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION.
WAIT A MINUTE, YOU ARE THE
FBI.
SOME GUY DID THE RIGHT THING
AND HE CALLED YOU.
AND HE SAID THIS KID IS ON
YOUTUBE SAYING WANT TO BE A
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOL SHOOTER.
HOW MANY PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY HAVE THE NAME
NIKOLAS CRUZ?
HOW MANY PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY HAVE THE NAME NIC
NIKOLAS WITH A K.
HOW MANY HAVE BOUGHT A GUN.
IF WE LEARNED ANYTHING FROM
9/11 IT’S THAT THE FEDERAL
AGENCIES DON’T CONNECT WITH
EACH OTHER.
THIS KID, ALL THE WARNINGS
WERE THERE.
ALL THEY NEEDED TO DO WAS
CONNECT THE DOTS AND THEY
DIDN’T.
>> Sean: I THINK, JUDGE, YOU
COULDN’T SAY IT ANY BETTER.
ALL RIGHT.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR INSIGHT.
WE’LL BE WATCHING YOU THIS